they pass rather patch for fractions
teams suits similar to clubs and spades
except each suit has its own face cards
there are also special cards when you
are the play wall it's like to be near
dawn for you get your game in the noggin
what a waste of time the earth shall
revolve around the Sun before you
comprehend these rules got a minute why
not al dirt get assistant professor in
contemporary history at Oxenford academy
Garrett of Vivian Witcher with tenure
I'm looking for a woman long hair
dressed in black and white seen anyone
like that of course not unlike the
populace I know the horsewoman of war is
pure poppycock gotta go salam a moment
would you you strike me as a man of the
world are you familiar with gwent no and
I don't have time to learn but the rules
are quite simple gum let's play
why not splendid here's how it's done
you
well you have a knack for this game if
you ever find yourself in oxenford and
wish to play a true master ask for
steppin a simple in keep i trade a true
maestra when it comes to wet I'll
remember that thanks